we've been following Donald Trump
serious golf playing during the
beginning of his presidency this is not
a story about golf it's a story about
broken campaign promises and lies and
fiscal conservatism and double standards
Trump's administration has been caught
lying twice about Trump's golf playing
saying that he was doing really really
important stuff he was actually just
playing golf and last week Trump was
seen in Instagram pictures playing golf
when the press pool was told he was in
meetings Trump went back to the same
club in Northern Virginia this past
weekend to play golf with Rand Paul this
was his 14th game of golf in 10 weeks
this was at Trump national golf course
so of course Trump benefiting from these
golf trips and it is costing taxpayers a
lot more because businesses aren't
having to go through the usual bidding
process to get the president to show up
there he just shows up at his own
businesses the government also paying
for food lodging entertainment etc and
it allows Trump to promote his
properties and raise their profile also
Secret Service has asked for a 60
million dollar budget increase because
of how frequently Donald Trump is
visiting his own properties and because
his wife and child are living in Trump
Tower what about going to Camp David
while Trump doesn't really like Camp
David he previously said quote Camp
David is very rustic it's nice you'd
like it you know how long you'd like it
for about 30 minutes Camp David
apparently not suitable for Donald Trump
you'll remember that during Obama's
presidency Donald Trump tweeted
something like 26 times about Obama
golfing too much including one tweet
where he said can you believe that with
all of the problems and difficulties
facing the u.s. President Obama spent
the day playing golf
worse than Carter and that a campaign
rally last year Donald Trump said you
know what and I love golf but if I were
in the White House I don't think I'd
ever see Turnberry again I don't think
I'd ever see Doral again I own Doral in
Miami I don't think I'd ever see many of
the places that I have I don't think
that I'd see anything I just want to
stay in the White House and work my ass
off make great deals right who's gonna
leave I mean who's gonna leave at this
point in his presidency President Obama
hadn't played a single game of golf
having been in office
many something days Trump has played
about a game and a half of golf per week
on average about two games of golf every
three weeks
Trump has visited his own properties
once every three days during his
presidency on average this reminds me of
that scene from so Trump's golfing is
not even really that that good in
September of 2015 the managing editor of
Sports Illustrated said that he was
playing golf with Trump once and after a
break they came back to the green and
there was a ball ten feet from the hole
that wasn't there before
and he asked Trump about it and Trump
said the guys I play with cheat all the
time and their reminds me of this scene
from the double-oh-seven
movie Goldfinger when James Bond was
playing with the villain Goldfinger and
Goldfinger would cheat by getting his
caddy to place a new ball on the ground
by dropping it through his pant leg that
is what it sounds like golfing with
Trump would be like and and when I think
about it Trump kind of looks like
Goldfinger doesn't he to come back to
the point here this is not about golf
it's about a broken campaign promise
that Trump wasn't going to be doing this
it's about the White House lying and
saying Trump is in meetings it's about
the golf trips being really expensive
and Trump claiming to be fiscally
conservative and it's about a double
standard because Trump slammed Obama
four years for playing golf and is out
golfing Obama by orders of magnitude I
would love to see Barack Obama go back
and look at those tweets and retweet
them now yeah now that we've known that
Trump is golfing at a far higher rate
than he ever did but of course Obama
isn't that kind of person no Obama seems
busy working on other projects at this
point probably getting more done than
what Trump is getting done as president